olha pessoal nome hartung e avivar da
importância de respeitar a distância das
de outros crimes
na maioria das vezes ninguém escolhe o
time a gente nasce no time da barriga da
mãe lá dente já erros dos tios dos avós
uniforme de futebol provou casa minha
avó queria que fosse gremista minha mãe
são paulino
ah mas eu sou santista teve novo nos
melhores amigos anjos diferentes
o roberto corintiano o felipe londrino
um pouquinho permanente não mas tem um
sentido ou outro felipe nunca pensei no
time deles para escolhermos como os meus
filhos amigos porque a amizade vem no
coração e nos amigos somos diferentes
todos nós somos diferentes mas respeito
a algo que precisamos por todas as
pessoas
no futebol nem eminentes do time que os
setores a gente vibra quando greg fazê
lo
a gente até queria queria que aquele gol
fosse do meu tio do seu time isso é
respeito
esses atos de violência afasta agentes
do futebol
a força deve estar dentro do campo fante
grita gol vai vai até xinga mas na hora
do jogo só é brincar a gente ia como se
fosse um gol
o desrespeito é moda do caso a caso de
cartão amarelo mas viu a violência vai
ficar alguém chega de cartão vermelho
expulsão é difícil entender que o
futebol sempre vai haver um campeão um
dia seu time pode ganhar
outro pode perder pode pt bonito e pode
perder feio eu estava no set a 1 do
brasil contra a alemanha e continuo
sendo um brasileiro com muito orgulho me
lembro como os alemães respeitaram não
houve violência campos turísticos
perdemos em casa e bem feio mas bola pra
frente quem é penta é o brasil
mas dessa vez as olimpíadas caiu brasil
encontra amanhã de novo mas venho dessa
vez e estava lá de novo
futebol arte alegria amor é isso que a
gente quer ver quando vamos ao campo e
falando nisso uma mensagem do meu
jogador favorito
há uns queridos amigos eu estou aqui com
alguns dos meus anos no rio neto e vamos
estar com vocês ou essa pesada pra você
se olha
ganhar ou perder é parte do esporte
então você precisa entender que isso
acontece
perdeu as três da outro ganha mas o
importante é o respeito
o euro é importante você sair que todos
estão no mesmo barco e um futebol o
esporte é um dos maiores meios de
comunicação ea mesa num no entanto boa
sorte é novo no brasil
muito obrigada